Hello everybody, hope that you are good.
This video is going to be quite
important because
we're going to start with a bit of
education. I'm going to explain my
thought process behind the last Bitcoin
Sunday update that played out
almost perfectly and I'm very pleased
because it took me a long time and so it
took me around 4 hours to to do that.
So,
always happy when things work in in the
right direction. So, we're going to
start with that. Then we're going to of
course going to talk about high time
frame.
We're going to be discussing whether if
this is the bottom or not or if Bitcoin
is going to enter bear market. And also
we're going to jump into Ethereum
for a bit. I found a fractal. I'm not a
fan of fractals because price action is
unique in its time. So, it doesn't have
to repeat, but I found something quite
similar that I would like to share with
you guys.
And then we're going to talk a bit about
Solana and and Dow and stuff. So, we're
going to start with Bitcoin, okay?
1-hour time frame guys,
this was the Bitcoin Sunday update. You
have it there. And so you understand the
moment that what what I posted.
Basically, you can see that is this.
Then, you know, that part is this part.
This little consolidation is here, okay?
You guys are following. And then this
drop here is basically this. So, this is
the moment where I started doing the
Bitcoin Sunday update.
So, when I did this update, I was pretty
much thinking of, you know, potential
drop lower and consolidation. That's
what we saw exactly in this zone, okay?
Then a push up, a little wick up to 84K.
We got that there. You can see how we
hit 84K. That is because of the 1-hour
50 MA. I was trying to figure it out
where was it going to position itself,
okay? So,
got that part right. Hit the 1-hour 50
MA resistance. And this moment was the
biggest challenge of the analysis
because I had to decide whether if the
1-hour 50 MA was going to be resistance
or if it's going to break through it.
I decided that it was going to be
resistance and we're going to see a
rejection. And that was based on the
idea that we created a new CME gap that
weekend
around 86K due to this drop here over
the weekend, okay?
I noticed that everybody was talking
about the CME gaps, you know, because
last weekend we created one and we
filled it the same week.
We also just filled a CME gap from a few
months ago. So, everybody was looking at
this CME gap at 86K. And of course the
market likes to, you know,
give you a tiny bit to then do the
opposite the next time. So, I was
thinking, okay, this time
it's possible we're going to do
something different because it's going
to catch everybody off guard. So, that's
what I thought, okay, that's the moment
where we will see a reaction and then a
big drop, very sharp as you can see
there, to 77K. Basically, because that's
where the weekly 50 MA is, which is the
biggest bull market support
historically. So, I was expecting to get
there to to get a retest. And of course
to see a bounce, a very good bounce to
81K. That is what we just seen
today, okay? So, that was my thought
process behind the Bitcoin Sunday
update.
It acts I mean, it's not something that
you cannot that you can take for the
next Sunday because I just analyze
each case in a different way based on
logic and
intuition, okay? So,
um
again, happy that it played out because
it's an analysis that I share for free.
So, it feels good to be honest. Then, if
we go into the weekly time frame, and
this is where the fun begins, okay? Is
the bottom in? So, to answer the
question of whether if this is the
bottom or not, then I need to look at
what happens previously and from a
historical data point of view, what
happens at the 50 EMA in the weekly time
frame, okay? Which is
the most important and the biggest, the
strongest bull and bear market
indicator, okay? Because when you're
above it, you're in a bull market, but
when you lose it and you retest a
resistance like what happened here in
this yellow rectangle,
then that is telling you, yes, we're
entering a bear market. So, as you can
see, pretty much right now we're at the
most critical area, the most critical
level that Bitcoin can be at. So, look
at what happens here, June 2021, okay?
You see an uptrend, retrace, retest a
support of the weekly 50 MA,
continuation, you make a new high. Here,
June 2023, the same. You see an uptrend,
retrace, retest a
support and continuation, new high.
Happens here again, August 2024 guys.
Uptrend, retrace, retest a support,
continuation, you make a new high. Is it
going to happen again? Uptrend, retrace,
retest a support, continuation.
Okay? That is what I'm looking at here.
Of course, it might be too early to say
that because, you know, we still have 5
days left until we close this weekly
candle. So, we we are just at the
beginning of the week.
We still have a lot to go, but
personally, I do believe that it's more
likely to close this weekly candle above
the weekly 50 MA
signaling support. But again,
tomorrow we have the CPI data. So,
who knows? There is going to be
volatility. Are things going to turn,
you know? It's possible. I would like
again, and I do think based on
intuition,
that that was the bottom. We are going
to hold the weekly 50 MA
and we should see bounces from here,
okay?
And we should see a bounce from here
potentially into new highs. That's what
I'm thinking based on
what I believe this cycle is is going. I
don't think that was the top. Simply
because when it's the top, people won't
think it's the top, okay?
Right now, if you go on Twitter or you
go in any other social media, you're
going to see a lot of people almost
50/50 probably discussing that this was
the top, okay? That the top is in. And
at least that's what I see. So, also
market sentiment here being so bearish,
the stock market also is rolling over. I
don't know. Maybe I'm completely wrong.
We'll see it in a few months, but I do
think that it's again likely, more
likely that we hold the weekly 50 MA.
The question is for how long though
because as you can see in these previous
cases, we actually retested
for a few weeks, even 1-2 months.
Okay? For example here, we tested in May
2021.
And it's not until the end of July
when we break out, okay? So, that's
basically 2 months there around the
weekly 50 MA. Then what happened here
for example is a bit different because
you are, you know, playing around the
weekly 50 MA for 1 month, then you see a
bounce, then it falls again, little fake
out there. This case is a bit different.
Really, here we we were a much longer
time. And the last time we've been here
was in June of last year and we didn't
break out until September, okay? So,
well, really July from September, so
that's 3 months, okay? 2-3 months of
consolidating around that area. So,
that's what I'm telling you guys. Who
knows? It's possible that we get an
instant bounce from here. But
based on a historical basis, you know,
it's more likely that we,
you know,
hang around these levels for, you know,
March, April, and then maybe in May
we can start to move up.
Okay? If that's the case that we
actually hold this level. And of course
the evaluation is very simple.
Give me what happened in December 2021.
Close this weekly candle, that we still
have 5 days, close it below the weekly
50 MA, and then for the next few weeks
test it as resistance. Then what is more
likely that we start to roll over at
least to 52K, potentially here there is
a wick that we could fill and that's at
40K, all right? But again,
I do think that that could be less
likely in this moment, okay? Uh based on
my personal opinion. Okay, we'll see
what happens. Maybe I'm completely wrong
on this. But that's my take, okay?
Then,
but so basically I'm answering the
question if this is this the bottom or
not.
I do think, yes.
If this is a bull market and it's not
over, this needs to be the bottom. Okay?
That needs to be the bottom. Again, in
these few weeks that we're going to be,
you know, hanging around this level,
this weekly 50 MA, potentially we could
spike a bit lower, you know, with wicks,
but the candle closing above it. That's
for example what happened here in May
2021. Also, it happened pretty much in
all the in in most of all Well,
basically in all previous cases, okay?
You see little wicks below the weekly 50
MA, but my point is that
from a structural point of view, the
weekly 50 MA is the level where we are
closing weekly candles
and that is indicating a bottom, okay?
That's what I want to see. The next
question is what is happening for
example with Ethereum. So I don't want
to check the Bitcoin Ethereum versus
Bitcoin although you can see that
we are making new and new lows so I
would like to see
a bounce very close from here but
potentially
in this area here
but again it's very difficult to tell so
I'm not going to jump into
conclusions. But if we check the
Ethereum
in the with the dollar pair
you can see something here if we put the
two weeks time frame, okay?
So what is happening right now as you
can see is that we have been in a very
very
tight range between 4,000
and 2,000. All right? You can see that
4,000 was the range highs very clearly
there. You get three retests
and the range lows at 2,000 you also
have the three retests. Now what is
happening is that this new setup a
potential breakdown
but it could turn to be a deviation with
time, okay? For example, if we see
this would be of course the clearest
signal ever, okay? But if we
close this weekly candle
with a wick, okay? And we actually close
it back above 2,000
that would be the clearest signal that
this was a deviation, you know? They're
going to start to well in the next
candle
you would start to see re- real retest
of the range lows
and you'd go again to the range highs.
Okay? That would be the clearest signal
and if you pay attention
this is something that we've seen
before.
We've seen that
in here.
If I zoom out like this
you're going to notice the similarities,
okay?
There's only one difference,
so first of all
this is the type of deviation that I'm
talking about. That wick there
but the weekly candle closes above the
range lows. That's what I would like to
see, okay? Oh that that would be the
most obvious signal that that's a
deviation and we are seeing something
similar to what happened here.
And also the difference was this long
wick that we had to the upside
which of course we don't have that now
and it's the same because when I see a
long wick like that to the upside in an
uptrend
all I'm thinking is you know, we're
going to bounce to fill the wick.
And we don't have that right now so of
course I don't I don't I don't have the
same confidence as I would have had back
in 2016 when this happened.
But the structure is very similar, okay?
So again I'm not a fan of fractals
because price action is different in
each time and a lot of things have
changed since 2016 to now. The liquidity
for example is not the same at all. It
was much easier to move prices back at
this time than now. Right now for
example you even have the US government
you know, playing with Ethereum,
Bitcoin, Solana, XRP. So there is much
more manipulation.
Okay? But
it's true that it was easier to move
price back at the time, okay? By retail
in 2016. So
that's something to pay attention to and
if that ends up to be the case then you
can just wait if you want to do the end
of the week and if we close the weekly
candle above 2,100
that's your confirmation.
Personally I don't really see Ethereum
going much lower than this, okay?
So
personally I bought quite a few spot at
1,990
2,000 exactly so
in this area here
I loaded in in the spot, all right? And
the reason why I did that is because I
knew that you know, it's likely that
Bitcoin goes back to the weekly 50 MA
and it's likely that if that's the case
Ethereum drops lower but not that much
lower. How much more can it drop? To
1,750?
Well, we've got that.
I've added the spot there. How much can
it can it go lower? Personally I do
think that it can go as low maximum
as 1,500. I don't see it going lower
than that to be honest, okay? So in my
opinion
all this area here
it's a great area to add in a spot,
okay?
That's what I think. Again
as long as the weekly 50 MA holds for
Bitcoin because if that's not the case
then Ethereum is going to you know,
continue going lower to maybe 1,000 or
below it so
everything depends on Bitcoin right now.
But
if Bitcoin is about to hold this level
and we're going to see a potential next
well another potential leg up then
I just think that that's a good level
for Ethereum between 2,000 and 1,600 or
so. That's the area where you know, you
want to buy in a spot. All right? So
that's just my opinion.
And then let's finish because this is
going
it's
been quite long.
If you go to Solana
and you go to the weekly time frame
you guys can see here how you know, you
have a very clear range highs, range
lows. Going to the daily time frame
they're going to see them better here,
okay?
Look at this level. Look at 120. Look
what happens at 120. How many retests
can we get, please?
1 2 3 4 5 6
7 now.
Okay? This are very high time frame
support.
Again
if Bitcoin is going to hold
the weekly 50 MA
which we don't know if it will but if we
bet that it will
then I believe that it's a good area to
buy. That's where I bought my Solana
between 120 and 130, okay?
And I've said this when we were here at
175 when we were dropping before well
before even this drop
I was marking this level, okay? At the
range low. So that's what I'm thinking,
okay? Between 130 120
Solana is good.
Of course we can wick below it.
It happens most of the time.
You can see here how many times we wick
below it. We even went for example here
to 105
110. It's normal. This time we're going
to 112.
These wicks here are normal. It doesn't
mean anything, you know? What matters is
how we close
those candles and for example today we
will be closing
below the range lows if it closes like
this
and that would signal a deviation and
then a potential recovery of this zone,
okay? For example here you have a
liquidity pool here. That
red candle there is a big liquidity pool
that we're going to go back to in the
future, okay? So
that's a few thoughts.
Again not a bear, not a bull. It's just
TA.
My TA says that
there is no confirmation of a bear
market. Everyone that is saying this is
a bear market
they are gambling.
Okay?
There is no confirmation of it. You
know, we are holding
in Bitcoin.
Let me see.
We are holding
so far and we have actually retested
the weekly 50 MA.
And these kinds of drops here. Look at
for example this. This drop was a 25%.
Okay?
This drop
a 17%.
This drop a 46%.
And we've dropped
a 28%.
All of these have previously been
in hindsight you can see that they've
been corrections before the next leg up.
And they were only corrective moves to
retest the bull market support level
that is the weekly 50 MA before the next
leg up. All right? So the question is
are we seeing the same thing? So far
yes because we just retested and we're
holding above it. Things will change
again if we drop below it, close below
it, test it as resistance for a few
weeks then yes. That's your bear market
signal. Then yes, you can say that this
is a bear market. You can tell your
followers to sell their bags like
they're saying now
and you know, Bitcoin can drop again.
But so far that's not the case.
All right? So far we're holding above
support so
again just a video to keep your feet on
the ground to bring you a bit of
to bring you a bit of logic and and
sense to this world that is very chaotic
and this is just how I'm playing it,
okay? So
we're still in a bull market until
proven otherwise. Thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you soon.